[Music]
two years ago chef and restaurateur ken
peshotta had a dream
he bought the river rock in in milford
pennsylvania a charming town nestled in
the stunning pocono mountains just two
hours drive from manhattan it was a
golden opportunity the light shown upon
me to come this way
but soon after we got the keys the dream
turned into a nightmare i was expecting
to reach a certain number on room sales
and i didn't hit one tenth of that
i don't think kenny has an idea how to
run an inn
and the few guests that do come are far
from impressed there's nothing in the
bathroom no shampoo no conditioner soap
nothing we have to go out and buy some
if i came in i would probably check
right back out it is like old it's
trying to be cozy but it's not it's
hideous if i wanted to stay at my grams
i could pack back and go stay at my
grams i'm not going to a b b
for that
if you're buying in you got to step up
and be an innkeeper we need to fill
these rooms we really do
facing financial disaster ken was forced
to move out of his house and into the
inn
i said ken you're making the biggest
mistake my name is
ken is now 48 single living and he's
crumbling in and hundreds of thousands
of dollars in debt the more the hotel
fails two thousand eight hundred and
sixty eight dollars in taxes that i
still do the more controlling ken
becomes
he just takes everything out on us to
make our lives feel miserable just like
his
you don't feel very good about yourself
as an employee kind of
chips away at your
sense of self
i i don't know what's going on i told
you i'd buy you a little time so like
he's down here everybody's walking on
eggshells everybody's afraid to do their
job they don't want to be yelled at flip
come here [ __ ] yourself everybody
threatens to quit it's a daily event
yeah things don't get better here i'm
definitely leaving you know what you
really need to grow up an actor age or a
48 year old man just get the [ __ ] out of
my face the progression of events has
just turned it all into a hot mess and
it doesn't matter what we do it's just a
hot flipping mess
rocking an american beast
wow
where's the reception
[Music]
right
anyone in
it's like a hallway not a check-in desk
unless she's behind there
hello hello
somebody's ashes are down there bloody
hell
just like my granddad's house hello
uh where's the reception uh this is it
basically this is it sheps and it should
be out in a minute if you like okay
thank you very much well hello nice to
you it's nice to see you i'm karen
o'shawn it's a pleasure to meet you i'm
a little bit nervous then yeah you were
nervous yeah honestly i was just like
standing here on my own oh well i'm
sorry i apologize for that um it's
confusing where's the reception desk
it's right here right this was the
reception desk can i just quickly show
you something yes
i know i don't mind getting stuck in
well
oh dear oh dear that is pretty bad yeah
that's not very pleasant that's not at
all pleasant
uh so
would you like to go to your room uh
yeah
follow me this way
okay
how old is this place this hotel was
built around 1880s i think it was
decorated in 1880 it kind of looks that
way for the first time in the last time
it's been a while for the rooms there is
a closet over here
they uh
special hangers just for me oh yep
wow wow i think the coat will stay
what is that
lobster extra carpeting we just got new
carpeting here okay so it's uh save for
repair i've never had free carpet in my
wardrobe before
okay
just check my view
ugh look at those bugs
and the blue bottle is stained for the
week
there's like a little forester down here
we give these
to your cleaner sorry
it's like an insect funeral home
truthfully in the fall there was like a
ladybug problem bringing it in guest and
oh my gosh it would be like you know 50
bugs in the room and so ken and i would
take care of that to get rid of the
ladybugs for the people to stay
um
now they've died and look at this here
i think that's a cockroach to welcome me
on the toilet no way having a number two
i'm just like i can't believe it look at
that i've never had a cockroach
committee welcome me on the john let's
get out of here well what else is on
this floor well this is the owner's
quarters and all these bits of furniture
do people literally sit that seems to
work well to for internet service out
here
okay so this is the wi-fi chair yes it
really is i'm gonna bear that in mind if
i need to check my emails
[Music]
it's so sketchy at best
okay
far worse than i thought through
gordon's eyes i was like whoa it's
totally neglected i'll uh i'll unpack
and get ready for dinner
okay
welcome to milford and he's a joke
gotta go it was horrible the place is
filthy it's something
my first impressions of the inn have
been dreadful at least i can take my
mind off things with some tv
nothing look at that
i knew those shitty hangers would come
in useful for something
[ __ ] come on i can't believe i'm gonna
miss the simpsons come on
dan
this is embarrassing
110 dollars for this [ __ ] hole
just the general hygiene cleanliness is
just
shocking
the wardrobe's full of crap
and there's no excuse
for dead insects and filth everywhere
it's like they've given up
and no one knows there's a hotel here
because it's just not fit
to rent these rooms out for the public i
mean look at it
if this is what the bedrooms are like
god knows what dinner's gonna be like
so far at milford pennsylvania's river
rock inn i've discovered outdated decor
bugs galore look at that i've never had
a cockroach committee welcome me on the
john
and a tv that last worked in 1982
i've heard that the owner is a chef so
maybe the restaurant will be the river
rocks saving grace okay
good to see you and it's ken isn't it
yes sir there's an american bistro
outside yes is it a classic beast cherry
yes
everything made from scratch that's nice
you're a chef by trade yes i am are you
not in the kitchen tonight uh no i'm not
working on a line so you've retired from
cooking
some like running the path maybe or i'm
running the other side i'm just watching
all the food and letting setting
everything out it's hard to run this
whole place by yourself
i have so many years of experience i
thought that when he hired me he'd be
able to
let go a little bit knowing that i could
get this job done but he just can't seem
to let go um and how would you rate the
food one to ten seven or eight and if i
asked you to rate your rooms out of ten
what would you give them four or five
i'm now [ __ ] myself
about dinner
let's hope that the food is better than
the rooms sure
the concept of an american bistro
serving fresh local food in the country
inn makes perfect sense but i can't make
any sense of this menu oh well um i'm
getting a little bit confused because
we've gone mexican on the quesadilla
we've jumped down to thailand and then
we got italian for the calamari
what american bistro yes yeah wow um
what would you recommend on the menu we
do a house smoked trout i believe that
it's a golden trout from northern
california it comes in frozen you're
recommending the i.e frozen trout from
northern california you know chef
it's been only frozen once right your
head is sweating
it's a little hot in here you're
dripping again that's me i'm sorry i
know i feel like i got a leak at my
[ __ ] bottom
your bold head
who puts these ideas together that would
be kenny's chef
okay um so give me a tie sampler please
yes sure yeah uh entree dying to see
that valve
i'm traveling around the globe in
milford enjoy
i'm appalled i was promised an american
bistro instead i get a sampling from
around the world
i was expecting fresh food but i get
recommended frozen fish what's going on
here your thai sampler chef
are they made in house no they are
nachos thank you jason
[Music]
wow
it's just frozen crab reheated and how
can you make slice of chicken look so
bland i wouldn't give that thai
experience to my [ __ ] dog
[Music]
l6 is on the fire too james i'm
struggling yes sir where's the chef from
is he a local boy yes he is i think left
to his own devices he'd do very well
he's very limited on what he can use for
ingredient-wise because he doesn't do
the shopping who does the shopping now
kenny does the shop so he's almost like
cut the balls of the chef off yes sir m6
m14
menu at the river rock is pretty much
outdated uh it's kenny's menu
it's been here for years i don't agree
with the menu but it's he's my boss he
pays my my salary i'm still going to get
to that point where he just kind of
burnt out
[Music]
hey gordon hamrick how are you tough on
this one what do you do here i bartend
and i help manage ken's a chef and the
chef that's cooking is not allowed to
cook his own dishes yeah it's almost
like he's sort of cut his balls off well
that's kind of what he does with all of
us are he
deflates you strips your confidence
won't let you make any decisions
executive or otherwise that's crazy and
it's a lot of micromanagement why'd you
stay here and i'm a loyal dog
unfortunately i'd bend over backwards
for him but
that bones weren't thin
ribaldo
mr chef ramsay that might be the golden
ticket
wow
[Music]
thank you
thank you
jesus christ and writer it's like
someone's just dropped a [ __ ] t-rex
foot on my plate
honestly
in fact that might be a small valdestar
oh that's a small one yeah sure
i mean it's like a meal for eight
that valdistano can feed an ethiopian
family of 40. you know what i mean
horrific this is not what i would expect
in a country inn it's worse than a nasty
roadside diner i feel like i'm eating a
[ __ ] flip-flop with mayonnaise
ken the owner looks like a zombie
sleepwalking towards disaster it's time
to get everyone together and see if i
can wake ken up how much money are you
losing per month right now about five to
seven thousand on one and that's on the
decline correct if those rooms aren't
that busy
why are they so disgustingly dirty
they they're dirty because i didn't
check them
it's almost like we're robbing
customers
when i arrived you gave your food seven
or eight out of ten yes but the food was
dreadful
seth how long have you been cooking
almost 18 years as a chef 18 years in
the business are you proud of what you
serve
personally i don't agree with kenny's
menu it's on the menu so i want what i
want i know what i want you can't hold
people's hands in this business
if you don't fix this inn they've all
lost their job
i honestly think that kenny needs
somebody to open his eyes so that he can
see that everybody that works for him is
capable and we're dependable and we're
here to help him increase his business
and make it successful and nobody's here
to hurt him i'm here to help
it's impossible because you
are not helping yourself
and it's not as if you're the captain of
the titanic you're the [ __ ] iceberg
[Music]
you haven't stared at yourself long
enough in the mirror and actually
understood where the issues are
you're looking at them
good night
[ __ ] me
oh jesus
i've had about all i can take for one
day
it's time to get to bed
but based on how neglected these rooms
are i need to know exactly what i'm
sleeping on my black light will reveal
any bodily fluids previous guests have
left behind
the bed
oh jesus christ that has got to be semen
this is hotel hell
before my first night sleeping at the
river rocking in milford pennsylvania i
decided to check it out with my black
light to make sure there was nothing i
wasn't seeing
and i was appalled to discover a vast
spread of bodily fluid stains has this
thing ever been washed people pay to
sleep
in this bed
i'm
[ __ ] believable
there is no way i'm sleeping on these
sheets tonight luckily i came prepared
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i forgot to turn off the lights
[Music]
oh man
that was rough
hopefully a shower will wash away the
memory of those awful stains
[ __ ]
look at this thing
ah [ __ ] me it's like being in danny
devito's house in the shower
come
now than i did on i got in here [ __ ]
it's freezing
i don't think the staff or the owner
have any idea how revolting it is to be
a guest here i want you to come upstairs
with me i want to show you something
placing all of you
time for a wake-up call
[Music]
good morning good morning these are the
guests that have been staying in the
hotel
now you've all experienced over the last
24 hours a sleepover
and what i'm here to do is to help fix
this place i can't do it without your
feedback
my biggest complaint was this morning
when i took a shower um i had water up
to my ankles before i got out my shower
head i probably showered from here down
because the shower head hit me about
here there was like bugs on the floor
and then
i was sitting on the bed and then i saw
a bug on the door too i have back
problems and this morning it was really
hard to get out of bed um just cause you
could feel the springs
the big question for me is that on the
back of last night's experience who
would
stay here again
a little raise of hands
i probably wouldn't come to stay again
really no one
thank you very much
thank you i hope ken is starting to see
how his lack of effort at the end is
driving guests away there's one more
thing i want to show him if this doesn't
wake him up nothing will i'm gonna show
you something that is
pretty horrific
come in uh just stand over there please
three of you
glasses on
brace yourself karen
[Music]
oh my goodness
i'm disgusting
it's awful i don't even like to think of
what i'm even looking at it's like a
[ __ ] galaxy
this is foul
absolutely foul i'm shell-shocked a
little bit it's disgusting it's truly
disgusting the sameness makes me sick to
my stomach oh dear
i don't know what to say i mean i'm just
it was a horror show
it was horrifying i was thinking how
many times has this room even been
rented without being cleaned
for all that to be there ken you're
running a [ __ ] hotel
not a brothel it is [ __ ] disgusting
start taking responsibility
i've discovered some disgusting things
at the river rocking
horrific food
to my [ __ ] dog
dead bugs it's like an insect funeral
home and i've worked out what the source
of all the problems is
it's ken and it's not as if you're the
captain of the titanic you're the
[ __ ] iceberg
[Music]
he's in way over his head and making
everyone's life miserable as a result
and his incompetence has let the inn
fall into a shocking state
it's like a [ __ ] galaxy it's awful i
don't even like to think of what i'm
even looking at this is truly disgusting
[Music]
it's a true slap in the face i apologize
to everybody who slept there before
that i put you through that i think it's
horrible
i hope ken realizes now that there's
more to running an inn than just owning
an inn
this place needs to change and change
fast
yes
elise just wait to get stuff
first up the inn needs to be cleaned so
it's a place fit for paying guests to
stay in
i put the whole team to work to clean
the in from top to bottom
and i'm going to address the worst
problem myself
hello madam hi how are you very well
thank you is there any chance i can put
this through a wash
yes when do you need advice by tonight
yes definitely
but can you do a sort of extra strong
cleaning product it's pretty rancid
[Music]
okay so uh be careful we'll be done
thank you bye-bye
carefully don't catch anything
[Music]
wow
the place is looking so fresh
while the staff finished cleaning the
inn i want to have a snoop around the
kitchen and see if there's any more
clues as to how ken is running this
place everywhere
who writes notes like this
why do i have to ask weekly for the fish
to be eyes down
do not take this sign down
do not take my pens buy your own if you
use this drill replace it while buying
you one with your paycheck
bloody hell charming
ken definitely has issues bloody cow if
you eat these cookies take one to your
next job interview
i mean my god i'm surprised anyone still
[ __ ] works here
this guy
is incredible that's not management
this is insane i can't believe ken is so
passive-aggressive with his staff
i need to talk to him and find out what
the hell is going on i come across all
these little notes about don't take this
if you do take it to your next interview
you tell me what's going on
i i don't like being taken advantage of
i have some hard times with things that
they do
then why aren't you talking to them
why aren't you
leading them why aren't you motivating
them why aren't you getting close to
them
the secret of any good management's
about communication understanding
and putting yourself on their level
maybe i look at it as they should be on
my level who are you kidding
come with me i want to show you
something
take a seat here
ken thinks he's managing his staff but i
think he's bullying them he needs to see
how he's making them feel i've set up a
monitor in one of the bedrooms and i'm
gonna force ken to watch a staff meeting
i think this might bring about the
change this place desperately needs stay
here i'll be back in five
[Music]
i came here to help
what i'm frustrated about is what i'm
discovering i've snooped around the
kitchen i come across this
a cookie jar
if you eat these cookies
take one to your next job interview
we call those kenny's nasty grams
i mean is this a joke or is this no
that's real
i put those notes up because my staff
needs reminders for me to tell them to
do the simplest task
they can come off as degrading but i
don't know if they get the hint there
any other way what in the hell is going
on look at this one don't take my pens
buy your own i think he hides behind
he's afraid of confrontation it's
passive aggressive seth how does that
make you feel he causes us all to be
discouraged in the jobs that we have
there's so many people here that really
know their jobs well but we have become
discouraged and when people become
discouraged they don't do the things
that are necessary
[Music]
there's no gratitude like so when you
say to us why why are we like this we're
just spirit-less he's really just sucked
the soul out of every one of us
he's just a spirit sucker honestly
[Music]
i'd lock ken the owner of milford's
river rock inn into a bedroom where you
can watch a staff meeting on tv if you
eat these cookies take one to your next
job interview the staff have told me his
management style has destroyed their
morale is this a joke is this that's him
every day there's no gratitude like so
when you say to us why why are we like
this we're just spiritless he's really
just sucked the soul out of every one of
us individually over the period and
length of time
he's just a spirit sucker honestly
anne-marie's comments about me brought
tears to my eyes her especially because
she's one of my closest friends
it did hurt me what do you want to see
change from him let the people his team
do the work that he's hired us to do
this place can succeed providing that
you stay on track you've got to stand up
to him
let me go and get him
i hope that seeing that finally got
through to ken it's time to reveal to
the staff that he was upstairs watching
every word
wow
of what my staff thinks about me it's
awakening
it it really saddens me because i would
do anything for them and i feel that
they don't see that
i need to change
i uh
watched everything you said
and
i apologize
i never wanted to suck the life at any
of you
and uh
i think i control this place
but realize maybe i don't need the
control
you have a good team here and if we are
going to move forward
you have to give them ownership of their
own areas uh seth yep you've got to get
that mojo back and i'm falling back in
love with what you've employed to do
uh karen uh you care and that's what
being a good innkeeper that little
personal touch
you should have a
hold on the inside of this business and
sort of filling the place like the in
hotel manager so i want you to have that
level of responsibility
i think what i learned the most was that
i need to give people the opportunity to
run this place i can't micromanage like
i always did
i really hope that he backs off and lets
us all do our jobs he just has to put
the faith in us and i know that our team
can accomplish anything
[Music]
i think ken's warming to the idea of
change
but i don't feel i've got to the heart
of why he looks like a man under such
extreme pressure
kenny have you got two minutes
sure thing
come on in
there's got to be more to this than
money
yesterday in many ways i started to
believe you you'd given up today we
turned the corner we've got to stay on
that track
i thought i thought i'd control this
place and it didn't work
it's not working it seems like the
pressure you're under is not just
financial right
in order to buy this place i borrowed
from my brother i said i think i could
really make this work and and the price
is affordable
would you help me
after we met with the owners
he went to the truck and says
how much do you want me to write the
checkout for
he's my idol
and my mother too my mother it wouldn't
happen without her help either i said
i could move to this restaurant to this
place and the only way i could do it is
i need some money from you i needed 50
000
and she also said
just take it
[Music]
so both their houses are
tied into here
so this place fails
you have let them down
and yourself
this entire place wouldn't be
here without my brother and my mother's
help i want the business to succeed so
they don't have to have a worry i don't
want to ever let them down and you can't
do it alone yeah i know do you have a
girlfriend in here
no no don't take this the wrong way but
it needs a it needs a woman's touch yeah
it needs a bit of a feminine approach it
needs that kind of love no yes it's been
kind of rough there's been no lady in my
life because i haven't been had a chance
to go out there
and and even meet or date women i just
want to meet that special person and
just a big deep breath
it's the first time i smiled in a while
because
the river rocking has come a long way
from where we started the once filthy in
is now clean and ken the owner has seen
the error of his ways i apologize
i never wanted to suck the life at any
of you but before this place is ready to
welcome guests the staff need to
understand the true meaning of
hospitality this place is definitely on
the road to recovery but i think this
team needs some training so i've asked a
very special friend ramesh sedwali from
caesars
palace i'm gonna actually show them how
it's done
hi gordon good to see you hi how are you
thank you how are you oh great please
take a seat it's so nice to see you it's
great to see you so
the customer focus is critical isn't it
very much and in your mind what are the
golden rules
in the first 60 seconds
you have to approach a guest with a big
smile on your face because that just
opens all kinds of doors find little
ways to to make a lasting impression on
that guest and let them know that their
comfort and their enjoyment is your
primary objective and it sounds simple
but it's not that simple if you practice
all the basics the rest of it will just
fall into place it has to be natural
people know when you're not being
sincere the good news is the team here
you know their heart is in the right
place but they are clearly lacking
training okay the owner doesn't smile
that often so okay all right let me go
get the team okay
thanks ramesh
kenny we've got someone very special
want to introduce you to please come
through i'd like to introduce you to a
very uh very dear friend of mine
please my name is ramesh ramesh very
nice to meet you he's from caesar's
palace he's flown in from vegas i asked
ramesh to come and teach you how to
greet
customers
holy mackerel here's the guy that runs
caesar's palace coming to teach my staff
how lucky of a guy am i
he's here to help you and to show you
within 60 seconds of those guests
arriving through that door what we need
to hit
first impressions go wrong they never
forget it okay
why don't we have a look at what they
normally do stop straight away and we
restart okay
stop
as soon as you see a guest coming
through there you can come out here and
reach for the door open the door and
have a big smile on your face you look
like you just lost your arm
here we go
bollocks
okay put a lot more into it okay it's
gotta be good afternoon it's great to
have you here welcome it was kind of
hard i'm gonna work to get better at
greeting people good afternoon nice to
have you here welcome to the river rock
inn thank you very much stop
before he extends his hand out to you
you should have extended your hand out
to him i feel like i'm being yelled at
by a drill sergeant you're out on the
stairs karen your turn
karen you have an incredible smile that
was a little nervous gordon's in the
back and he's chanting you know you
could do this you could do this you know
and give it a pep talk here we go
[Music]
good afternoon i'm karen welcome to the
river rock afternoon my name is james
sanfilippo i'm here to check in welcome
mr sam felipe come right this way
i see that you'll be staying with us for
the next week yes ma'am possibly more of
it of course that would be wonderful we
have you staying in our king-size room
which is on the second floor absolutely
lovely room with a pretty view out the
front of the house so that's a nice
place to be nice
finally
amazing karen is a superstar
she really is that was very well done
gordon helped me realize that i have
people that i can rely on and instead of
being
the hands-on owner
i should be more of the overseeing owner
which i really need to be very well done
right
[Music]
now that ramesh has taught the staff how
to make the right first impression i'm
going to try and help ken boost his
self-esteem which will make him a much
better innkeeper ken meet barbie barbie
meet ken nice to meet you nice to meet
you i've flown in barbie hatch a
hollywood stylist to give him a new look
this one's a little bit too big for you
a different shirt maybe
while barbie gets to work on
transforming ken i want to check out the
inn's website
and see if that's also in need of a
makeover
this is supposed to be the wi-fi chair
and i can't even get
any signal
[ __ ]
one bar
[Music]
there's amazing competition in this town
so
in order to stand out and sort of be
somewhat different you do need a great
website
my goodness the opening page on the
website looks as old and frumpy as the
interior of the bedrooms i mean it's so
dated
it's like it's been put together on a 20
budget shocking he obviously doesn't
realize that 80 of hotel bookings are
done online today so
if you've got no decent website to
follow then you're absolutely screwed uh
come back to me signal
[Music]
let's see it's great it really works you
don't have to put on a parka you just
throw us around your neck you're done
let's do it
thank you so much you're so welcome
ken's makeover is finished and i'm gonna
take him out on the town but first let's
see what his staff think
your new
innkeeper
very very nice yeah yes very handsome
let's go
[Music]
i'm taking ken to a local bar i think
that meeting the right girl will give
him a great confidence boost the sort of
positive energy that will light up the
river rock and make kent a pleasure to
deal with
quite a lively little place take a seat
how dapper does kenny look
yeah he does doesn't he thank you
how could that man still be single
yes tomorrow night oh yes relaunch it
tomorrow yeah re-launch the end tomorrow
night and so it's going to be awesome so
can we have a little toast to kenny
finding a girlfriend no kenny come on
girlfriend
it was a really great eagle boost i felt
like the king boy he really set me up
thank you very much
if i fail now i'm really a loser
big day tomorrow
in the morning that's wishes good night
honestly i've never seen a man change so
much um let's just hope he's not late
for breakfast in the morning
[Music]
my design team worked through the night
to transform milford pennsylvania's
river rock in and now it's time to
reveal the changes to ken and his team
good morning good morning how are we
very good good seth how you feeling
great great excellent all of you this
week have really put so much effort in
to get this in
back on track so i'm greatly
appreciative for your efforts it's only
fitting okay that we start the relaunch
with a proper
sign take a look at this
it's not
the old side from the old restaurant
it's a beautiful sign river rockin and
restaurants the best food and lodging in
the podcast how cool is that it's very
cool is it nice beautiful it's wonderful
thank you okay ready to go inside yeah
excited let's go
come through are you ready
it's a beautiful place to live and stay
another place you've got to come and die
first off we have a stunning color on
the walls gone is that hideous paper so
now it's in keeping with a rustic charm
and all the bugs are gone too the
changes are just incredible i'm a bit
overwhelmed by them i'm blown away
totally blown away we replaced that
dinosaur tv with a new flat screen
guess what it works
okay
replacing the mattresses stunning linen
oh my goodness
new table lamps and guess what gone
are the spunk stains
karen the only milky way from the skies
above
yes
it's karen what do you think i think
it's absolutely beautiful it's still a
country inn but it's
a country end of the year 2012.
let me show you the room next door
please
this is incredible
this is just amazing gordon just did
wonders here oh by the way what
i've updated your router okay so you can
have wi-fi in the room inside the room
oh my god how cool is that
amazing hello i'm blown away you're
blown away worn away excellent
oh wow please come in wow
look at this come in come in come in
when i first arrived the check-in was so
confusing
now the guests come in
they sit down
we offer them a coffee glass of water
and then
we'll go to actually booking them
in online
[Laughter]
how cool is that that is
easy now how much do you spend on linen
a month a fortune a fortune underneath
tablecloths you had these stunning
natural tables which were just being
hidden at a ridiculous expense
focus on the linen upstairs in the room
before gordon was here i just had a
restaurant now i have an inn i have a
destination i can't wait i'm looking
forward to the relaunch tonight we're
going to have a lot of fun you like us
thank you yeah
you like it
with a new decor and ramesh's expert
training hello welcome to the river rock
i'm karen along with a newly inspired
ken
how you been enjoy your dinner thank you
the river rock is in a much better place
time to go when i got here ken
honestly that guy was a hopeless
innkeeper almost like someone had given
up but
yeah we've turned him around it's almost
like he's sort of he's got his mojo back
and now
river rock has every chance of
succeeding i tell you what i've seen a
lot of skies
but not quite a milky way like that
[ __ ] me as i prepare to leave guests are
arriving for the relaunch
and i noticed some familiar faces from
the bar last night and as promised
they've brought a friend how are you my
daddy nice to meet you
oh you're the doubt
a little bit
first impressions
he looks cute it looks cute
nice
i can feel a good night coming on wow
[Music]
joey i need three onion soups two fish
cakes and fish fingers with ken trusting
his staff and not micromanaging he's
able to spend more time on the floor
hello my friends leaving time to charm
the mills of milford hello how's
everyone tonight welcome and this is
hi kelly nice to meet you hi ken nice to
meet you
follow me
come on wake up
i was excited to see them she was very
pretty i look forward to talking with
her here we go ladies
thank you so much
my first impressions of ken he looks
cute very
we'll see how the night goes salute
ladies thank you very much
[Music]
the inn is buzzing and ken has invited
some very special guests to see the
place at its best and this is my brother
oh how are you sir
lout wise good to see you too and my
mother hello madam how are you how are
you very well thank you nice to meet you
there's no words to express how proud i
am of dennis upstairs the guests are
loving the new rooms and downstairs
they're loving the fresh local menu that
chef seth and i put together really
really good
before i can leave there's one last
thing i need to take care of you have
your cell number please
not for me if i can come on
thank you
amazing listen thank you so much for
coming tonight i really appreciate it
thank you
ken come here
now how are you feeling i feel wonderful
honestly at the beginning of the week i
thought you're gonna sort of almost
i suppose fall to the wayside but you
bounce back and i'm grateful for that
thank you i'm grateful for you oh and
one more thing
[Music]
kim's cell number
can't have a better wingman than gordon
ramsay holy [ __ ] he gave me her number
it's in my pocket
no more sticky notes nothing let them do
it
yeah okay
i love you this is the greatest thank
you so much gordon made me realize that
i should be less of the hands-on owner
who can't see the forest through the
trees from here on i'm empowering my
staff to make their own decisions and
i'm going to support them
no more micromanaging for me
[Music]
what a week what a galaxy
[ __ ] me
you